AND THAT IS SOMEHOW GOING TO BE
AN OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE TELLS
YOU HOW DESPERATE THE LEFT IS
GETTING.
>> Sean: FORMER SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, NEWT GINGRICH, CALLING
OUT THE SCHIZOPHRENIC INSANITY.
NOW FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, SARA
CARTER.
A NON-STORY ABOUT A NON-EVENT.
THAT SUMS UP THE HYSTERIA
YESTERDAY.
BUT WHAT THEY MISSED YESTERDAY
IS WHAT YOU WERE AND WE WERE
REPORTING AND THAT IS JUST HOW
ABUSIVELY BIAS STRZOK AND PAGE
WERE AND HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE IN
THE LOOP KNOWING THE FIX WAS IN
AS IT RELATES TO DOING A REAL
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY
CLINTON BEFORE THEY INTERVIEWED
HER, EXONERATIONS BEFORE ANY
INVESTIGATION.
UNPEELING EVERY LAYER OF THIS
ONION.
>> AS INVESTIGATION COMES OUT
ABOUT THE FBI AND TEXT MESSAGING
UNRAVEL, YOU GET A LEAK LIKE
THIS THAT GOES TO "THE NEW YORK
TIMES."
IT'S A NON STORY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS EVERY RIGHT TO
QUESTION WHETHER SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER IS RIGHT FOR THE JOB AND
HAS THE RIGHT TO DISCUSS IT
PRIVATELY WITH HIS ATTORNEYS.
AS WE SEE, NOTHING HAPPENED.
SO HE DIDN'T FIRE SPECIAL
COUNSEL MUELLER.
HE TALKED ABOUT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AROUND SPECIAL
COUNSEL MUELLER.
THERE WAS NO ORDER TO FIRE HIM.
WHAT IS FRUSTRATING IS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT GETTING
WELL INFORMED BY ALL THESE VERY
IMPORTANT NEWS AGENCIES, "THE
NEW YORK TIMES," "THE WASHINGTON
POST", CNN.
WE KNOW THE FBI -- AND LET'S GO
BACK TO THE STORY WE TALKED
ABOUT THE OTHER DAY, SEAN, THE
FACT THE DOJ SAID WE LOST FIVE
MONTHS OF TEXT MESSAGES THROUGH
A TECHNICAL GLITCH AND YOU WON'T
BE ABLE TO GET THEM AND NOW THEY
HAVE THEM.
WHY DID THEY SAY THAT TO BEGIN
WITH, WHAT ARE THEY HIDING?
>> Sean: WHY DIDN'T ROB
THIS.
ONE ROLE THE JUDICIAL WATCH HAS
PLAYED KEY IN GETTING
INFORMATION -- I KNOW YOU FILE A
LOT OF FREEDOM OF INFORMATION
ACT REQUESTS.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE'LL GET THE
MEMOS NEXT WEEK PROBABLY AFTER
THE STATE OF THE UNION BUT WHY
DO WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR THE
50,000 TEXT MESSAGES.
RECEIVIVE
RECEIVIV
RECEIVIVE  -- RESPONSIVE AND
LAWSUITS AND GETTING THE RUN
AROUND AND THEY TOLD US IF YOU
WANT THEM, SUE US AGAIN.
AND WE DID SUE THEM.
THEY FOUND THEM.
IT'S ABOUT THE NEWS STORY THAT
WAS PLANTED THIS WEEK ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CONCERNS ABOUT
MUELLER.
THE TEXT MESSAGES, THE
GAMESMANSHIP THERE, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FIGHTING THE HOUSE ON
RELEASING A SUMMARY MEMO OF THE
UNDERLYING MATERIAL.
IT'S ALL ABOUT PROTECTING THE
MUELLER OPERATION.
WHAT I THINK THE HEADLINE IS IN
LOOKING AT THE FIRING OF COMEY.
WHY IS HE NEAR THIS
INVESTIGATION GIVEN THAT
HAVING TO RAISE IT?
NOT CONFLICT FREE.
THAT'S THE ONE LEAK WE GOT.
NEXT WEEK'S A BIG NEWS WEEK.
TWO BIG INVESTIGATIVE REPORTS
YOU'LL BE BREAKING NEXT WEEK.
ONE ABOUT ANDREW WEISMAN IF I'M
ALLOWED TO TIP YOUR HAND FOR
YOU, BEING THE NICE GUY I AM,
WHAT'S COMING NEXT WEEK AND HOW
BIG DO YOU THINK THE MEMO ENDS
UP BEING.
>> FIRST, IT'S TRUE.
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON MEMBERS OF
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL AND ANDREW
WEISMAN HAS COME UP OVER AND
OVER.
HE'S VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE HE'S
A CENTRAL PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
I DO HAVE SOMETHING COMING OUT
NEXT WEEK WITH REGARD TO ANDREW
WEISMAN.
ANOTHER STORY THAT'S GOING TO BE
OUT NEXT WEEK IS THE FISA MEMO.
WE EXPECT THAT TO BE OUT SOME
TIME AFTER THE STATE OF THE
UNION IN MIDWEEK.
IT'S EXPLOSIVE.
AND IT'S A WAY TO KEEP THE
COUNTRY UP CHECK.
IT'S ONE PART OF SO MANY MORE
PIECES OF THE PUZZLE.
A LOT OF THE INFORMATION IS
CLASSIFIED.
IT'S CLASSIFIED INFORMATION SO
WE CAN'T GET OUR HAND ON IT.
THEY'LL GO AHEAD AND PUT OUT THE
PIECES, REDACT IT, I THINK AFTER
THE FISA MEMO.
>> ANDREW WEISMAN, THE NUMBER
TWO AT MUELLER'S OPERATION SEND
AN E-MAIL SUPPORTING SALLY
YATES' ORDER AND WENT TO HILLARY
CLINTON'S ELECTION-NIGHT PARTY.
>> Sean: AND HE LEAKED
INFORMATION ABOUT PAUL MANAFORT
BEFORE HE STARTED INVESTIGATING
HIM TO THE A.P.
SO MANY CONFLICTS ALL COMING